five opening logos I wonder what he is
right now
oh he's in one half of a continent
gotcha it takes a minute and 20 seconds
for this motorcycle who emerged from
this tunnel and drive 300 feet down the
road as this camera tracks it a man just
parked that thing anywhere I'm sure it
being in the middle of the road won't
ever be a problem idris elba isn't in a
better movie in this scene no one knows
how these soldiers infiltrated an island
fortress like this with all the security
and guards but they just must be that
good also how amazing is that they
attack right after Murrow said the boy
wasn't safe here the soldiers run down
the hallway scene requires four cuts all
in the same shot you know to make it
more exciting
who is this chick sudden important trick
is sudden Nadia shoots at good guy
Murrow after totally not using it when
the bad guy was pointing a gun at her
just a second ago Murrow spike was
definitely not parked on the very edge
of this thing when he came in shut up
boobie kills Giles in the first three
and a half minutes unlikely narration
over opening credits after four and a
half minutes of incomprehensible Bulls
animated rehash of the first movie
including cartoon ass kind of flying
it's on YouTube check it out no it isn't
no it isn't and no I shouldn't they made
a second one of these reenactment of the
first movies contract signing scene
contains many factual errors yeah that
is right I'm the guy who made the deal
with the devil except in the other movie
you barely got cut and a drop of your
blood just happened to land on the
signature line so it's not like you did
any real signing or anything that would
hold up as a contract in any court of
law
another cartoon ass our asses inherently
this funny to show two of them in 45
seconds but you did something you
wouldn't want the writer to see a white
lie an illegal download so the
ghostwriter concerns himself with white
lies and illegal downloads doesn't the
white lie portion of that cover nearly
everyone since when does he care about
that my brothers are dead as should I be
so that's hilarious
impossible and looks fake --is-- not to
mention geographically and spatially
dishonest also how the fuck did he find
Johnny if they don't even know each
other
does Moreau have ghostwriter detecting
powers so many times I've tried to keep
the rider from
but tonight I need him and we won't show
you that because our budget is fucking
bottom shelf Jesus they left the town
during the day but it took until the
darkest of night for them to finally
make their move on Nadia just let me go
I'm happy how does she not know that
Kerrigan will now hesitate and get
distracted by noises so that he doesn't
shoot Nadia and Johnny's hideout just
happens to be close enough to reach this
spot at whatever speed he was going to
prevent it at the last second 40 seconds
of here's the Ghost Rider drama in which
none of the kill heavy criminals even
attempt to shoot him this is looking
into the random bad guys soul scene
takes so long you'll swear it was just a
pad the movies runtime minor cut from
the kids cheek allows the drop of blood
to fall just so the ghost rider can get
distracted and no other blood comes out
so what the fuck and wouldn't they open
wound be enough for him to sense it
considering how easily the ghost rider
can kill fools why did he bother
spending all that time on that one dude
I'm going to go
Jesus mysterious new unexplained
slump-buster weapon is actually
effective against the devil soul
collector let's not bother taking Nadia
with us or killing her so that the ghost
rider has a lead he can follow so come
on and the freaking door is open too
why is Nadia here did the ghost rider
put her on the back of his motorcycle
and drive earlier and did he do that
instead of simply chasing after the bad
guys are you telling me they actually
had the power to hurt him enough that
his demon self was like this time to get
some medical care or did she drive them
here that can't be either because they
steal a tow truck later also hours after
the incident one of the odds that this
chick and the ghost rider would both be
in the hallway of the same hospital at
this exact moment I just uploaded a
little program a firewall off and on the
motorcycle won't be able to sense him
there the track was he able to track him
before I just thought he sent some evil
shit coming down and went after it not
oh my god I can sense an important kid
in my general area also this little
thing that devil just did he just made
that up right that particular power did
not exist until he decided it did and if
he's got that kind of power why doesn't
he just program the kid to get in a car
and drive to his location he still may
be able to find you so what's the
fucking point god damn these two are
always in the same place as each other
why did that one weapon caused such
lasting damage on the devil's right-hand
man why does any weapon do damage guns
don't but these slug Buster things make
him a hobbling mess some random girl
gets the jump on the motherfucking Ghost
Rider this must be the least busy
Hospital in the entire world
where this kind of confrontation can
happen in front of ambulances for you
knows you're what we call on the
screenwriting trade a lucky break also
we don't want the audience to know
anything yet yes for something in return
son I hear he's supposed to turn into
Keanu Reeves and win every case is a
lawyer later in life no movie thinks
this casual joke will forgive the fact
that this is exactly what she is in a
legitimate plot development why does the
devil walk on earth in human form
anywhere huh sudden narration also
hour-and-a-half movie goes cheap
animation for the sequence because my
uncle you're not paying that much
attention at this point are you if he
just passes on from body to body down
through history waiting for the perfect
fit
easy Jerry Springer joke is easy other
acceptable easy jokes include Paris
Hilton Kim Kardashian and Nickelback on
earth he's weak his powers are limited
why is that now who cares as long as we
somewhat know the mystical spiritual
rules and powers oh you can forget oh
don't worry this definitely fatal car
crash will fail to kill anyone important
oh sure now physics works the riders
come out destroy even though this movie
told us earlier the rider comes out
whenever it's in the mere presence of
whoever's got it coming in the presence
of evil I change into a monster I'll
just stand and stare at someone else for
five minutes so that you can get away or
pick up better weapons also if she's no
different why is he not Ghost Rider in
out and collecting her soul
movie rips off the Edward and Bella from
Twilight you're a bad liar Nicolas Cage
is entertaining to watch half-assed
crazy Nicolas Cage is simply bad acting
of course you do I don't know why his
ass ones fighting becoming the Ghost
Rider
he can't win this any other way and why
is his bike Battlecat when he is it even
he man yet also Nadia said she knew
where the quarry was but he's definitely
not following anybody and she's not
following him and couldn't if she tried
so how the hell does he know where to go
right now did she give him directions
even though he was well ahead of her
running a minute ago well they're not
speeding but these black tailgating SUVs
are still cliche in their evilness this
chick doesn't need any help from Ghost
Rider or anyone
she's a fucking magical teleporting
superhero of Justice why didn't you just
do that in the first place
wait a minute do you mean with the
breakneck speed with which he was riding
his motorcycle Nadia beat him here
basically killed this guy before and now
he's back with a vengeance
he doesn't need medical attention this
time though this is because the movie no
longer needs an 18 minute break in the
action to explain the block reload
because it's clearly such an effective
weapon
Ghost Rider pauses to scare the audience
he clearly could have done this earlier
and ended the movie but he was way more
interested in staring down that
unimportant day player for five minutes
I'm sorry
attention screenwriters when your
villain constantly spouts stuff like
this and Showtime and get some he has no
longer a character he's the guy who says
things he heard other people say in
movies once also this asshat is taunting
the writer after two failed attempts to
kill him with the best weapon he's got
on hand so more shooting these guys have
seen the Ghost Rider get pummeled by two
javelin missiles and shot multiple times
and it's clearly a byproduct of
something to stink lean on Jesus but
they keep the faith that the bullets
will work instead of running away or
shooting the guy that got them in this
mess I've got to get these sentiment
credit they saw the flaming demon
bastard of machinery here and they
didn't give up hope that the battle was
lost me I left this place and changed my
identity an hour ago but I'm not fit for
this business
Johnson you're taunting now can you not
just kill this dickhead and call it a
day Ryder leaves Kerrigan alive for no
good reason at all even the Ghost Rider
you've presented to us in two movies so
far does not have that kind of
superpower and we definitely know he
can't go anywhere without making lots of
noise this obvious approaching vehicle
never arrives I wish I had that cliche
I thought it was gonna sting your face
like this ladies and gentlemen is why
this movie is an hour and a half instead
of a tiny 42 minutes your legs are huh
all by itself yeah but that scar on his
face took days to heal for some reason
despite his amazing devil child powers I
think it's in cages contract that his
character has to do at least three
oddball things for no reason just to get
a laugh I've already contacted Moreau
he's gonna catch up with us on the road
what did you hit him up on his cellie
did you guys exchange emails we gotta
move fast because the ones who are
haunting us they're not I could have
killed them before I caught up to you
but that would have been too easy
no wonder bring me Nadya's son
replacement sequels Satan is replacement
also Satan can easily find his henchman
but cannot easily find his own son
without help I'm pretty sure we saw a
medical and police authorities on this
scene a moment ago right yeah we did
awesome sounds slow acting and fairly
useless against a skeleton Ghost Rider
but thanks no excuses just don't touch
him
wait can you control his decaying power
because I'm confused just a minute ago
when he didn't know he had the power
Roark had him touch this wood and it
instantly disintegrated so how does the
guy drive get nap devil children or
masturbate maybe there's a reason the
devil has to hire some other asshole to
go get his son but the movie doesn't
offer it which makes this seem kind of
stupid this guy failed so give him
superpowers and set him off to fail
again
brilliant seems like the perfect do it
yourself if you want it done right
scenario given the devil's apparent
power having a father/son style
conversation while taking care of a
motorcycle cliche machine last night you
made it change that's how it works
whatever he rides changes with him
doesn't that sound like something we
should have been told in the first movie
yeah it does fire Pete also hey guys we
need to get in this new to go to do that
fire being segments by God this movie
will fail miserably without a pee fire
so I want to see you all in here at the
studio at 5:00 a.m. sharp this power
that we have comes from a dark place but
it's not who we are
discount Batman Begins dialog I realize
he's the devil's son and probably can't
die or something still the mother
somehow allows this dangerous motorcycle
player well not one person involved
wearing a helmet also the interstates of
this great nation's highways are
completely devoid of traffic today so
it's easy to do motor stock
stunts and not have a care in the world
watching Ghost Rider do wheelies with
Satan's kid makes me wonder oh did this
movie ever get me yeah you see this is
the problem with having the power to
disintegrate anything you touch by the
way what about that steering wheel the
director said let's have you
disintegrate an apple it'll make you
look like even more of an asshole
ah Twinkies are indestructible I'd laugh
except the Simpsons did it and did it
like in the early 90s silly customer you
cannot hurt a Twinkie also why does an
undead minion if Satan need to eat so
this is a morose happy class narration
obviously added because we had no
fucking clue where they were going
discount Christopher Lim holy SH why
can't he come with us no after a burger
and ride on the back of the truck this
child of Satan decides to treat ghost
rider dude as his father because he's
and character development is hastened
the only thing that can hurt you well no
because all Danny has to do is say don't
hurt me and your fire goes out so not
really it'll be alright
uncapable promises this vulture would
fetch 50,000 euros that's an option
euros the dose was an angel a spirit of
justice so here's something our
animators whipped up real quick because
Sony only gave us one roll of film rods
down to hell corrupted and down in hell
something about war money and women on
earth something something stock footage
became the spirit of ashes
roll credits you must confess the one
thing that is most difficult for you to
talk about well that sounds like some
pulled out of a hat mystical mumbo-jumbo
if I've ever heard it and I have this is
the Lamb of God also known as the loaf
of bread also movie wants me to take
communion with stringer Bell where are
you going now again that's full all
movie rips off the Luke faces its demons
thing from The Empire Strikes Back
sealed off underground cave has a lot of
fucking light spiritual MRIs also the
Ghost Rider goes through some sort of
experience that's changing him and I
guess things are happening that's how I
would explain it to a kid anyway Johnny
wakes up from his religious experience
just in time to insert himself back into
the plot yeah methodius is kind of a
prick for lying to Murrow like that but
the guy has scriptures written on his
face man did you really think it would
protect the son of Satan circle-jerk you
know if you assholes weren't so timed to
the ritual killing you could have been
done with this an hour ago
how did Kerrigan know where to find all
these assholes also what is it with the
timing of all the assholes in this movie
when they start their trip they are
exactly the distance away they need to
be to stop something at the last second
it's astounding how we Bowl bad this
movie is this came from a major studio
how many good scripts were turned down
to make this piece of shit actually how
many good scripts upon hearing of this
movie's existence simply died
like literally disintegrated in the
writers hands as he or she went into a
studio to pitch it and scripts stored on
computers downloaded a cell virus and
left a suicide letter on notepad it's
gotta be scores of them write protectors
these turned out like you were doing a
better job on your own
at least they fucking cried to help man
this is a day of prophecy
movie was unable to resist talk of a
prophecy and introduces it 2/3 through
the movie the child must be miss
thirteenth year because at an arbitrary
age like 13 which sounds like a
milestone in the human world even though
it isn't it's just as important in the
demon world Danny
Onew I know why the hell didn't you tell
us this Moreau actually the only reason
he didn't tell you is because this is a
movie in case you confused it with
Jacques Jacques de Alabama not
disintegrating not disintegrating who's
that Gupton seriously also take that
Turkey do we really expect these weapons
to work against the devil or are these
just going to make the movie really loud
in a few minutes in apt analogy as me
just so we can revisit footage of the
fucking flame beat drug-based devil
cheating these three people aren't on
climbing rocks yet none of them is Tom
Cruise politicians people soldiers movie
tries to shoehorn in some half-assed
comment on politicians and rich people
being the devil's soldiers and while I'm
sure you'll get many to agree with that
assessment it's not like your movies
been planting all this brilliant subtext
throughout that makes this payoff in any
way for luck succeeds will have a new
form one more powerful
the shadow will fall upon earth oh you
met immediately that shadow fell quick
the world's politicians murderers and
people of influence who would want to
see the anointing of a new evil king or
basically the number of people who came
to see Terminator Genisys on opening
weekend Jesus Christ the fact that any
of this needs to be done to ensure
someone becomes the Antichrist is a sin
on its own
also the devil is doing this because he
needs a younger body but why didn't he
impregnate some woman in trouble a lot
sooner
this guy is lit for thousands of years
right this can't be a new thing to him
and surely there are plenty of women who
would do anything to improve their lives
even if it meant taking in some demon
seat does Johnny Blaze have any kind of
experience or fighting skills outside of
his ghost writer self that would allow
him to infiltrate Oh Satan's kids
confirmation ceremony with no problem
these guards do nothing at all nothing
Nic Cage without super power is
infiltrating a weird ritual this movie
as national treasure 3 whether or not it
wants to be welcome back to our
continued coverage of the Antichrist
yoga serum we take you live to young
Danny who appears to be getting his
first installment of evil on a glorious
night of Satanism we now take you to
Salman Rushdie and get some of his
insight Salman also when the
interruption in a ceremony such as this
happens does the underworld give you a
free pass do they understand or does it
highlight the silliness that you ever
needed a ceremony in the first place The
Devil's kid uses double powers to
somehow make Johnny the ghost writer
again but I thought the ceremony wasn't
over how does he have this kind of power
right now
he hasn't completely turned yet no by
the way thought he could only be the
ghost writer at night because so many
times he chooses not to pursue bad guys
for some dumb reason but here he is
crack it on chasing down evil ghost
writer victim will he'll
don't you I was never afraid of you
ghostrider suddenly gets a boost of
energy because of taunting oh my god
also when you hear the ghostwriters felt
one liner so you wonder why johnny was
ever worried that he'd hurt Danny and
his mom never once did we see him go
after someone innocent in these two
movies which would have been a cool
aspect of the story but oh well
dumb is dumb young do you make of a
scene where a flaming skeleton flips
over a car containing Satan and his son
except that no one in the scene is
actually in danger Oh
be prepared to witness the longest chain
ever I don't get if it's supernatural or
not this chain is off the chain movie
thinks it's keeping anyone in suspense
as to whether Danny is going to die in
this movie Oh
since the rider was an angel it went
crazy and to accentuate that I'm going
to show you what an angel looks like
when it goes Nicolas Cage Ghost Rider
finds the angel inside of him ex machina
by the way after what we heard about the
angel earlier is one of his powers
bringing people back to life my name is
Johnny Blair's just in case you haven't
heard that several times throughout two
movies so far it required two directors
to direct this movie
[Music]
there can be only one dilaudid valium
what do you got what they give you
dor Z Haldol how much how much a coffee
shop
what's from there nobody ever Rob's
restaurants bars liquor stores gas
stations you get your head blown off
sticking on him CPU is in rouen that
processor learning computer but Skynet
presets the switch to read only when you
send out alone I think we better get
indoors the sandpeople are easily
startled but they'll soon be back and in
greater numbers
[Music]
it is blue